le grand départ et dans une heure et les
bénévoles discutent de leur itinéraire
dans le garage juste derrière c'est la
mise au point des big
car ce n'est pas pour le trajet
d'environ 18 heures qu'on prépare ses
camions
mais pour leur destination finale la
guerre en y créant
des véhicules à quatre roues motrices 6
dont ils ont le plus besoin pour
défendre une idée le dit martine le
propriétaire du garage
nissan pickup paul une toyota toute la
rangée par ce soir et s'ajoute aux
quelque 60 qui ont déjà été livrés en
ukraine en moins de deux semaines déjà
la moitié lui ont été donnés comme ce
camion que vieille de déposer cet ancien
soldat
c'est le moins qu'on puisse faire dit et
quand ce ne sont pas des cadeaux might
and i qui les achète lui-même usagers
dit
en chef martin bridget a non seulement
fait le don de sa propre camionnette il
s'est offert pour la conduire cette nuit
avec ses autres bénévoles ils ont
traversé la lettonie la lituanie la
pologne ils vont entrer 100 m en ukraine
seulement parce que les hommes qui sont
de l'autre côté peuvent pas traverser
peuvent pas sortir du pays donc c'est la
seule façon de leur livrer ces véhicules
là qui vont servir dans quelques jours
aux forces de défense territoriale en
ukraine
à des milices comme celle ci qui ont
reçu les camions de la lettonie la
semaine dernière ils les utilisent déjà
sur le terrain en ukraine
avant de partir on y charge tout ce
qu'on peut pour survivre aux hostilités
y compris surtout le gallon d'essence et
des pièces de rechange comme citoyen de
la lettonie ils se mobilisent sans
hésiter wimax proches comme voisins et
nous aussi la russie dit-il l'ukraine
est un rappel de notre propre
vulnérabilité
et dit qu'il enverra des camions en
guise de solidarité jusqu'au tout
dernier bombardement du calme précaire
de la lettonie au chaos de l'ukraine
dans 24 heures ils seront au franc ni
site amaral thérèse pour radio-canada à
riga